okay everyone we will go ahead and get
started I'm very excited to be here this
is the last session of the last day of
NDC Oslo so everybody here watching you
are the real heroes of the conference
this will be a good session though this
should be a pretty fun one so I'm Jeff
Holland I'm program manager working
inside of Asher back in Seattle
Washington and I'm on the Azure
functions team so I'm program manager
for Azure functions which is one of the
core pieces of service for Microsoft
Azure that said a lot of what I'm going
to be talking today are going to be some
of the concepts to know about for as
your functions but they are not
necessarily unique to Azure at all a lot
of these practices are good for any even
distributed system all around but
especially around server lists so
whether you do or don't use Azure this
should still be useful for you but but
do use a sure you won't be sorry about
it so we're gonna go into a little bit
of an intro of functions and server
lists but we're gonna spend a lot of our
times on best practices architecture and
some examples so with that said in case
you aren't already familiar what are as
your functions in the very basic
definition of this is as your functions
much like other service providers allow
you to have your code executed in
response to some event so in this case
I've got a really simple code sample
this is in c-sharp and all this is
saying is I'm gonna get an HTTP trigger
request to some endpoint and whenever
that request comes in I want you to run
this little bit of code here now the
code you might want to run might be you
know scheduled based hey I want you to
run this sequel query every day at 1
o'clock p.m. it might be message base
like every time a message shows up on
some queue or stream base like stream
this data and constantly process it as
it comes in but it gives you as a
developer the flexibility to just write
your code and not have to worry about
the scale the hosting the resiliency of
the service
that's all managed for you out of the
box from as your fun excuse me as your
functions imma grab a drink real quick
so with that said a term that you have
probably heard a lot of this conference
been some great sessions already very
brief definition I'm gonna jump right
through this which is what is serverless
as your functions is a service
technology and service is about an
abstraction of servers first and
foremost like when I publish that code
that I just showed you I'm not worried
about how to host maintain patch and
secure the servers behind the scenes I
just focus on my code it is event-driven
the resources to run your code are
provisioned automatically for you
on-demand at whatever scale you might be
requesting so you attach it to some type
of event I've already given some
examples of those already
and you're only billed for when your
code is actually running so if I did
have a serverless API and nobody called
it during the entire month I wouldn't be
charged a dime and then if the next day
all the sudden I got you know thousands
of requests I'd only be charged for
those thousands of requests now as your
the service platform looks a little bit
different than you might see in other
cloud providers
there's actually three core components
we're not going to spend a lot of time
in these right two but I think it's
important to know as you consider what a
service architecture might be formed of
so the first one you have functions this
is you know the code that you write and
publish code that you want to run off of
some event and Azure there's also
something called as your logic apps I'll
show you just briefly what one of these
looks like in a second but these are
workflows this enables you to
orchestrate code or data in a service
fashion and there's also a service
called as your event grid which allows
you to route your events to different
pieces of your architecture so you might
say hey I want to be notified whenever
something happens on my virtual machine
or on my storage account or I want to be
notified whenever an employee is hired
by my company so I can go do some
something an event grid is the platform
piece that lets you wrap that
information now on top of it it's very
likely that a full application isn't
just going to be service code service
workflow done events you're gonna need
data
you're gonna need security potentially
for like user logins potentially some
intelligence on top of it as well so you
get rich integration with a bunch of
other services inside of the Azure cloud
to do things like store your data in a
nose
database or run machine learning to give
like order recommendations like maybe
you have an ordering API and you want to
send them an email and say hey you might
also be interested in these items
weaving those types of intelligent
services is very easy as well and then
something we're very proud of an a sure
that Microsoft's obviously always taken
very seriously is the development
tooling so I'll go through a bunch of
the this today whether it's monitoring
developing testing or even continuous
integration and continuous deployment
okay so that's kind of the overview of
service many of you might have already
known much of this let's talk about some
examples and one of the reason that I
personally really love service is just
because it's changed how I am able to
write applications so the first cloud
app I ever wrote was actually an app for
the Microsoft band if you were familiar
with that that short-lived product from
Microsoft this is a picture of the app
here what it was was a simple app so
that if you were a fan of sports you
could open up the app and you could say
hey I want to know about you know NBA
scores or football scores or whatever
scores it might be and your band would
then talk to the cloud I would get the
sport score of whatever game was
happening and send it to your wrist for
a point in time reference I built this
in 2015 right around the same time that
the Apple watch was released this was
the first application I'd ever written
that was callable through the cloud it
wasn't just like some app that ran on a
box it took me about a month to build I
spent a lot of time building this it was
a good learning exercise and I was
spending $80 a month for the server
behind the scenes that was powering this
application when I had one user I was
paying $80 a month and even you know
this is actually a picture from a news
article that picked up this app when
Microsoft band was just taking off and
when this news article hit I got a
thousand downloads like in one day and
it kept growing I was still paying $80 a
month but I also struggled to kind of
manage the spike in usage that I was
seeing the other challenge was because
of this was kind of built as just my VM
with a bunch of code that I'd Jerry
raked together one of the biggest pieces
of feedback I got when I first shipped
this was hey we want to be able to
follow Premier League or world
or whatever adults it might be and so to
add additional features was taking me a
really long time and was hard to update
because I just again had this virtual
machine so cool app fun experience but
took me a long time to build and was
painful to manage now if I look at this
year some of the different apps that I
built this is just one example of one of
the apps that I built this is actually a
picture of my doorbell at my house I
have an IOT doorbell that has a camera
on it and it will be able to detect
motion or sound and I want it to be able
to use that feed from my doorbell to do
some intelligent stuff so what actually
happens is when somebody comes to my
door you can see an image of the end
result I'll actually run this video feed
through some intelligence services if
you've given me access to know your
identity then I can actually do some
facial recognition I can detect the text
if any text is being spoken and all this
is just running monitoring my doorbell
24/7 this only took me two evenings to
build I actually wrote a few blogs about
how it was put together if you're
interested and just like I mentioned
with serverless this is only ever
running when somebody actually comes to
my door I don't have a lot of visitors
I'm not super popular so this means I'm
only spending about four dollars a month
right now to constantly be monitoring my
doorbell and a lot of that cost is
actually from the no sequel database the
functions themselves are actually zero
dollars they're free because I'm not
calling them enough this will
automatically scale to any traffic and
it's extensible and reusable so to give
you a sense for what kind of a service
app can look like in Azure I do want a
piece apart this doorbell one ok so just
an example this is Visual Studio code
and for this app my door Bo one it's
actually written in JavaScript so I just
have here a very simple Java function
which says hey on a timer I every 15
seconds go and check to see if anybody
is ringing my doorbell if somebody is
ringing my doorbell I want to send an
event out to let me know that someone
rang my doorbell and then it keeps
running and keeps checking my doorbell
so not a bunch of complex code I have to
write just check to see if somebody's at
my door if somebody's have my door
notify my application some of the nice
things to call out I talked about dev
tooling
I've got this extension directly inside
a Visual Studio code for Azure functions
or I can create updates and publish my
functions all from within this
experience I can even do things like set
a breakpoint and f5 run and this will
actually spin up the Azure functions
runtime inside a Visual Studio code so
that I could debug this live and hit a
breakpoint so you'll see here with all
this moving text this is just spun up
it's now checking locally on my machine
here I think I've set this one to see
every 15 seconds so within about 10
seconds or so you'll actually see this
breakpoint would get hit so some really
nice tooling in here as well to help me
build these in this case a JavaScript
function now what happens when that
event gets sent because this functions
not doing a whole lot right that's not
powering all that cool machine learning
stuff I showed you a second ago and
what's powering all of that this is the
only part you're going to be able to see
out your logic apps today so don't blink
this is actually the workflow that gets
kicked off from that event that's
running in my subscription okay so you
can see here's some of the different
runs that have happened
I can click into them and see the status
if I actually click Edit this is what an
Asscher logic app's looks like this is a
very useful tool for functions and for
service to orchestrate events so here
I'm listening for that
doorbell event so I'm saying hey wait to
see if my function sees that someone's
at my door bell and now I'm gonna
execute this process which can be pretty
long running the first thing is I'm
gonna wait until the recording is
finished this could take a few minutes
until somebody finally leaves my
doorstep once I know the recording is
finished I'm actually going to upload
that recording to an out-of-the-box
connector here inside of azure so this
is a connector for one of the cognitive
services or artificial intelligence
services in Azure they can actually take
a video feed and automatically process
emotions faces text all that other good
stuff so we'll go ahead and push that up
here I'll wait for that video to be
processed and then I can store the data
here one other thing I'll show you in
case you haven't seen launch apps before
if I wanted to continue to add some more
stuff when someone rings my doorbell
I've got all of these not only as your
functions that I can call I could also
call you know contain
running an Asscher container instances I
could call other connectors like
dynamics github whatever service I might
be using this is probably code I don't
have to write so this is great it's
awesome and now you know within two
evenings I have this code that's
constantly running and listening for
when someone's at my door Bell so just
an example of what a service app can
look like okay now we're gonna spend the
whole rest of the time talking about
functions so that's that's the service
architecture piece let's go deeper into
functions now a few key concepts to note
when you're writing as your functions
the core component that you're dealing
with is a function app and an app is
your unit of deployment it's your unit
of development it's also the unit of
scale so a single app will be scaled as
a unit you can have multiple functions
in an app but your app is your primary
unit of development deployment and scale
and it can have many functions inside of
it so again just to kind of tied the
knots together if you come back here to
my doorbell project this is my app here
this is my function app but actually I
have a few different functions I have
checked the rings I have get the current
recording I have store some data and
Cosmos DB these are all different
functions but they all live in the same
app so I can develop them and deploy
them together all of your functions will
have a trigger this is the event source
that it's listening for and the data
that will be passed in to let your
function know to execute every function
can only have one trigger and the
service itself will automatically be
listening to that source so you're not
you're not charged if it's listening to
something like a cue waiting for a
message to drop you're only charged once
that trigger fires and your code
actually runs the other piece which is
unique to as your functions is this
concept called bindings these can be
super useful for use you're developing
your functions bindings are data that
you can pull in or push out of your
function without having to integrate
with that service directly inside of
code so I have here a table these are
like our top whatever seven or eight
triggers and bindings that we have an
example and I'll walk through this in
just a second I might want to build a
service API with has your function so
HTTP would be the trigger I'm going to
be listening for an HTTP
Qwest but maybe I want to store some
data from that request in a database in
a no sequel database like cosmos DB now
I don't necessarily want to have to
write and manage my connection to cosmos
DB so I can use a binding to
automatically push data to cosmos DB as
part of my execution and I can describe
that integration through configuration
I'll show that to you in a second
alternatively maybe my endpoint I'm
getting in a query parameter for like an
ID or a path parameter for an ID and I
know that that ID maps to some data in
my storage account or like table storage
maybe I actually want to pull in data
from storage at the time of execution I
can use an input binding to tell my
function hey you're going to be
triggered from HTTP but also pull in
data from cosmos or storage or wherever
else at the time of execution if that
doesn't make sense right now that's okay
I'm going to show it to you in just a
second but just remember we have
triggers that start your event and
bindings which can allow you to flow
data in and out independent of the
trigger now one of the nice things about
Azure functions is that you do have a
number of different choices on where and
how you want to develop I actually have
some recommendations here though so you
can write and manage hauser functions
entirely in the azure portal there's a
little code editor you can run and test
I wouldn't recommend it for anything in
production though it's great for trying
things out if you have a really simple
script and you just want to play around
with out your functions or it's not a
very important script it's fine but
anything you're doing that will have the
words production associated with it
you're gonna want to use one of these
other editors because then you can do
things like source control and
continuous integration and automated
testing and all of the best practices
that you've been hearing about so visual
studio this is perfect for C sharp F
sharp anything dotnet related there's a
really nice visual studio integrated
tooling that gives you debugging
publishing integration with has your
functions it's perfect for that you can
use Visual Studio code I showed you I'm
writing I'm using my Mac right now so I
have Visual Studio code Visual Studio
code does support c-sharp
but if you have the option I do think
visual studio is a more natural place to
do that for now at least for me
personally but if you're writing
JavaScript Java or Python functions
Visual Studio code is a great fit again
it has that out-of-the-box tenth
out-of-the-box extension we also have
maven tooling for Java functions so you
could write your functions in IntelliJ
or eclipse if there's a different Java
editor you care about and really the
tools can be run anywhere so if there's
an editor here that you like that I
haven't listed it will still work
you just need to make sure you hook it
up to our CLI tools so that it runs for
you ok so I want to show you what this
looks like now I'm gonna do a really
quick walk through a building function
inside a visual studio this time from
scratch ok and the one I want to build
is actually what I described a little
bit in the example so I want to build an
API and I have here a cosmos DB no
sequel database inside of my Azure
account and I want to make an API so I
can get a request have that function
spin up on demand and then push that
data directly into cosmos DB so let's go
ahead and do that I'm gonna go ahead
here and say file new project and create
a brand new as your function project I
can choose whether I want to do this in
our version one I'll zoom in here I know
this is really small in our version one
runtime which is currently generally
available which is written and runs
dotnet framework functions or our
version two one which is in preview and
will be in preview for a few more weeks
which is dotnet standard it actually
runs dot in that core 2.1 which gives it
some nice benefits i'm actually gonna go
ahead and do this in the version to.net
core one and let's go ahead and say we
want it I'm just gonna do an empty
project for now ok so here's an empty
project inside a visual studio I don't
have any functions here yet so let's go
ahead and add one into this app remember
this is my app and an app can have many
functions and this is my unit of
development deployment and scale so
let's add a function into this project
and there's a bunch of different
triggers that I could choose from I
already mentioned I want this to be an
API so let's do HTTP triggered and this
will start for us right here okay let me
make sure our code is big enough so that
you can see a little bit of what's going
on
200% yes please I guess it doesn't like
to zoom hopefully this won't crash if so
that's fine we'll have to move on from
there this is what I get for running
inside of a virtual machine on my Mac on
battery power it looks like it didn't
like it that's okay
don't zoom in your code live but that
code right there was just an HTTP
function I won't show you for the sake
of waiting for this to reboot and making
sure we have time to go into some other
topics as we move forward but I could do
the same thing I did in Visual Studio
code set a breakpoint click the Run
button and everything would would run
for me and I'll do that in a second okay
now this is great but I need to
integrate now with with cosmos DB and
I'm gonna use that concept called
bindings Kay so I don't want to
necessarily have to write the
integration code with cosmos DB directly
I'd rather leverage these bindings so
one important thing to note is that
functions you can pull in different
extensions okay so we have an extension
for cosmos DB we have an extension for
service bus queues we have an extension
for as your event grid these are all
published through nougat so in this case
the first thing I'm going to do is make
sure I pull in the extension for cosmos
DB and actually have a nice keyboard
shortcut which is going to give me all
the code here so I'm gonna say hey in my
function app I want to install the
extension for cosmos DB the reason that
we make you install these extensions is
because we want the base image to be as
the lightweight as possible so you get
really good performance so if you want
to bring in any integrations with other
services we have you install them in
through nougat if you're using
JavaScript or Java those two links have
you know different ways to do those
packages but I won't go into those now
all right so now this is where I want to
define how that integration works in my
function this is where I'm actually
gonna write my binding I'm gonna paste
this in right now and then I'll walk
through it okay so what I've done here
is I've written an attribute on this
function I've said hey I want you to
integrate with cosmos DB I have a
database called function I have a
collection called function and I have a
connection string which is going to be
in an environment variable called cosmos
DB connection okay I don't want to paste
my actual connection string
here because you don't want to put
secrets inside of your code so I'm
actually just referencing an environment
variable which I'll set in just a second
now
what it's telling this to do is I'm
gonna have this variable called Docs
which is an out variable and my
parameter whatever I set to Doc's in
this case it's the string I could make
it a document I could change the type
depending on what type of type I want to
use but let's just leave it as a string
for now whatever I set as the value of
docs that's what it's going to push into
Cosmos DB for me okay so I'm going to
set this value for docs and push that to
this Cosmos DB database so the only code
I have to write is hey let's set that
Doc's variable to the request body that
I get from the HTTP request okay so with
that one line of code and this attribute
up here now whatever is in my request
body is going to create a record at my
cosmos DB database obviously I couldn't
manipulate and do whatever I want to do
with it now the last part I need to do
here before this will actually work is I
need to make sure that I'm setting this
environment variable okay so locally I
have this handy file which you probably
can't read very well called local dot
Settings JSON and that will let me set
local environment variables easier in
the cloud they're called application
settings but let's go ahead here and
we'll say hey I have this environment
variable and I want it to connect to
this oops this really long connection
string no one used this Cosmos DB
database no one look at the video
recording okay so that's it so that's my
function that I wrote quickly here I use
bindings to make my life a little bit
easier and now
let's go ahead and run this and test it
out okay so I'm gonna go ahead and click
the Run button I don't know where my
solution Explorer went things kind of
wigged out on me a second ago but it
doesn't really matter okay so I'm now
running this code I have my as your
functions runtime which is spun up
inside a visual studio this is the exact
same runtime that we'll be running when
I publish to the cloud so I know that if
it works on my local machine it will
work when I publish it because it's the
same runtime that's running here it's
given me this nice end point that I can
test locally so here's my add your
function now that I can test on my
machine so let's go ahead and copy this
endpoint I'm just gonna send a request
using postman this Windows machine is
really struggling but that's okay all
right so I'm gonna send a request to
that endpoint and I'm gonna pass in this
request body the shift keys like locked
right now but I'm not too worried about
it I don't think so let's just keep
going all right so let's go ahead and
click send it's gone ahead now and fired
off that function in fact if I come back
over here to the logs it return back
hello Jeff I could change this to
whatever I want it to as well like hello
NDC and go ahead and send this again and
now it says hello NDC and I can actually
see my logs that are been generated here
just to prove that this worked let's
come look at this cosmos DB database now
in the cloud and if I click refresh we
should now see two new documents that
got created for me one with the request
body of name is NDC and this is just the
metadata that cosmos DB generates and
the other one which is named Jeff so now
I have this function that I could write
check in the source control and then
deploy once I'm ready to go
which is now integrating with cosmos DB
as an azure function okay so hopefully
if you hadn't used functions before
that's a bit of a walk through of how
some of those concepts weave into what a
function looks like okay so now that
you've seen functions it's useful to
know some of the common architectures
where I've seen these fit in very well
with some of our customers so here's the
top five scenarios that I've seen the
first one is any time you have an event
stream that you want to be doing some
processing on so these events might be
IOT events coming from IOT devices or
Machinery anything that's like in an
event hub or kafka something that's
pushing a ton of data diagnostic logs
whatever it is because the nice part
about functions is that I can just write
the code I want to execute for a single
event and click publish and now that
piece of code will run for every single
event that's happening so it's kind of
very easy to just attach this to the
stream and have it scale automatically
to do some processing on top of that
stream web api is a mobile backends is
another very popular one one of our
larger customers has a mobile app for a
retail store and how it works is if you
want to send somebody like a gift card
you open up the mobile app and you're
like hey I want to send Jeff $20 and you
select my account and you click send
when you click that send button and it's
actually kicking off some as your
functions behind the scenes which go and
charge their accounts and the email do
all those other great things and it's a
great fit forum because they don't have
to worry about managing this API and
scaling it they just publish this as a
function and it works you'll hear
serverless
often used and talked about as glue
between systems you might have a bunch
of data that's in some file system and
you want that data in a sequel database
or in a no sequel database being able to
just really simply write a function and
say hey whenever new data gets added or
every hour go pull the data and push it
over to this system is a really nice fit
to just kind of glue things together
if you're using pubsubhubbub ESB type
patterns and then for just general
automation or scripting if there's ever
a task that you're doing that you want
to automate something very simple like
recently I was just on a call with a
customer who uses functions to help
automate their pull request process so
they have it so that whenever anybody
opens up a pull request it fires off a
function that does some code checks very
quickly for them it's not they don't
have pull requests happening 24/7 but
whenever they do now this code can run
one of the customers I'll just share one
use case Carl Zeiss who does very
high-end electronics and imaging devices
they've been using Azure functions
there's a use case they published two
strimer stop Microsoft comm that
monitors and scales to field devices
that are connecting to back-end REST API
s and that's all powered by functions
and just to kind of bring the point home
and so I'm not the only one saying it
the thing that they call out is that the
scalability of Azure functions is
amazing they can send millions of
records in the platform adjusts
automatically to the load so very low
operations and very high scale okay now
let's talk about some more advanced tips
and best practices these are some of the
common hiccups that I see people do when
there's a support ticket that comes in
or somebody says hey Jeff I tried to use
functions and things aren't working as I
expected these are some of the top
things that I've seen and how to get
around them the first is another concept
to understand which is how instances and
resources are managed actually I do want
to show you this because it's a little
bit easier to show so let's come back
here to this let me open up my solution
Explorer wherever that went what do I do
view here view solution Explorer so this
has your function okay very simple REST
API this is in my app let's say I go
ahead now and publish this to the cloud
okay I have one just like this it's
already published I'm not going to go
through this now and what I do want to
show though is I have here a live stream
connected to application insight so one
of the tips is hook your Azure functions
into a monitoring solution like
application insights which we integrate
with out of the box because it will give
you insights and observability into how
your function is performing now what I'm
going to do here is that I actually have
a script ready to run which uses a load
testing tool called artillery and I want
to simulate 1,000 requests happening
every single second at one of those
function api's like I just wrote okay
now nothing has been called yet like
this thing is totally empty in fact just
to show this I'll call it one time
really quickly let's call this API and
you'll see what happens here in our live
monitoring so I can actually see that an
instance has now spun up to execute that
request right and it's already done you
see I had one one execution that
happened one lonely execution now I'm
gonna run this load test I'm going
push a thousand requests a second at
this function and I want you to pay
attention to the instances down here so
there's a thousand requests coming in
and you'll see how quickly and how many
servers are going to be scaled up behind
the scenes to process this load so
suspense now is high let's go ahead and
run this test let me wait for it to
start up and initialize I think it
should be going so we'll come back here
yep it started up ICOC already before I
finished my first sentence we're at four
servers that have spun up online and are
helping process the requests in fact
it's seeing that the load isn't stopping
so now it's at five servers six servers
very quickly this has been able to scale
up as the requests per second continues
to increase seven servers you can see
counter up here eight servers this is
nice if any of you have had to deploy a
server before it usually is not as quick
as this sentence that I'm completing
right now but already that function that
we wrote a second ago is now processing
across nine different servers and it
looks like it's hitting about 500
requests a second right now the
requester ations still really low so I
don't know if my my computer is bogged
down by me having too many things open
and it's not sending more than 500 a
second but that's okay regardless you
can see I'm processing 500 requests a
second across nine fully powered as your
servers running right now it looks like
this is very happy at 500 requests a
second so I'm just gonna stop this right
now to save my computer from blowing up
okay so we'll go ahead and stop that
okay so a few things to note is we
talked about what just happened so as
your functions will automatically add
instances or servers as needed in this
case for this load test it realized it
needs nine fully powered servers running
in the cloud to process that load each
of those instances will have my app
running on top of it okay so that same
runtime you saw me running in visual
studio those are running on all of those
instances now every single one of those
instances may be executing multiple
things in parallel right these are
powerful servers I don't need to just do
one request per server I could be
processing multiple multiple requests in
parallel per instance so there is some
parallel
I'm here happening even on top of an
instance for a single instance now the
reason this is important and one of the
best practices to know is that you can
take advantage of the fact that yes
there are servers powering server lists
and you can reuse certain resources
across executions so for example a very
common example of this is a sequel
client in your code maybe your code
needs to talk to a sequel database in
you're using sequel client a very common
mistake that people make is that in
their code they will do something like
var sequel clients equals new sequel
client and then my connection string now
the problem with this is that every
single time my function executes it's
going to instantiate a brand new sequel
client and have to establish a brand new
connection to that sequel server but
we're not throwing away your servers
after every single execution in fact
you'll notice if I even come back here
to the monitoring solution we have I
still have nine servers online all of
the code that I instantiated all of the
public or private static variables are
still set they still preserve their
values so if I would have done something
like private static sequel client that
sequel client would have only had to
establish one connection and that
connection could still be alive and I
could reuse it for subsequent executions
okay
so again here's the anti pattern that I
see a lot of people do HTTP client is
the other one this comes up a lot this
is an anti-pattern for a number of
reasons if you're interested there's a
link down here ok so here's my function
code does it matter the language if I do
something like using var client equals
new HTTP client that means for every one
of those thousand requests that are
coming in I'm having to instantiate a
whole new HTTP client my instance is
going to be really inefficient but I'm
also going to exhaust the available
sockets pretty quickly because there's
only a limited amount of sockets I have
on one of these VMs and if I'm pushing
high load I'm gonna exhaust them just
because I'm not managing things very
well ok so again there's a link here if
you're interested just remember these
instances are established but you can
actually reuse resources across the
you can almost have kind of simple
caches as well so the better way to do
this I'm gonna create an HTTP client as
a singleton in this case a private
static HTTP client this is thread safe
and what this will enable me to do is
now as multiple requests are coming in I
can reuse the same client and make
multiple requests so my codes gonna be a
lot more performant it's gonna scale a
lot nicer and I'm not gonna run out of a
sockets okay so this could be sequel
client this could be event hook client
this could even be some type of an
in-memory dictionary or cache and that's
gonna hang around you can keep reusing
that as you want so very very important
tip that's gonna make a big difference
and if you don't do it things might
start working quirky for you okay moving
right along because I want to give
plenty of time for durable the last tip
I'm gonna give in regards to scale I'm
gonna paint a little story for you okay
so if you think about this example we
just did with the HTTP load test where
unfortunately I wasn't able to push a
big enough load that's okay imagine that
we have two cities ok city a and city B
and everybody on city a wants to get
over to city B and let's say there's
that 1,000 people who want to get across
and I have one vote now the question
that I have to answer is how many people
can I fit on one boat for one trip to
city B now if these are small children
right maybe they're like 5 years old
maybe I could fit like 30 people on one
of those boat trips and that's cool
because it means I have to take less
trips back and forth but if they're
bigger people maybe it's like a thousand
people who are my size maybe I can only
fit like two or three people on one of
these boats before I get worried about
it ok don't worry I'm gonna tie this
back into functions I promise now even
if I have multiple boats like maybe I
have 10 boats or 20 boats there's still
the question I have to answer which is
how many people can fit on a single boat
at one time maybe I have a thousand
boats and that's ok but I want to make
sure that I don't load too much onto a
single boat by itself ok so just
remember that things can scale out
across multiple boats but I need to make
sure I'm aware of how many things can
fit on a boat at one time now what does
this have to do with how's your
functions
so you just softer that HTTP example
that I scaled out to a bunch of
different instances and the service
itself does as good of a job as it can
to allocate and distribute your your
load so that each of these instances
isn't processing too much we do our best
effort but sometimes our best effort
isn't perfect okay and we understand
that we're not perfect at this and so we
may do something like push too many
executions onto one instance at one time
we would overfill your boat okay so you
want to make sure that your function
isn't having to execute too much on one
of these single instances now when as
your functions just so you know a single
instance is one and a half gigs of
memory and one core of CPU so you can
think in terms of how much can I process
in a gig and a half of memory in one
core CPU if for some reason we've gotten
the math wrong you're using some of the
monitoring like I've just shown you and
it looks like we're overloading an
instance like it's memory utilization is
bad or it's starting to timeout or get
overwhelmed we do give you this
configuration file which is called the
host dot JSON file where you can
actually tell us how much we can send
and how much data we can push to a
single instance and that will allow our
scaling to compensate for it and scale
out appropriately okay so in this case
for like a very simple if I'm just doing
simple addition like hey take value 1
and add it to value 2 I could probably
be doing a hundred of those in parallel
at a time it's not doing that much work
but maybe I'm doing like Bitcoin mining
a cryptocurrency it's not profitable
don't do it on functions but if I was
that's probably more memory or CPU
intensive I might want to tell as your
functions
hey don't send too much on a single
instance okay there's a lot more
information here in terms of scalability
so that you can control how functions
scale to preserve things like downstream
systems I'm not going to go into that
right now but just note that there's a
lot of config here that you should be
aware of and this again applies to just
distributed systems in parallel
processing in general ok the other thing
I'll let you know is that without your
functions you do have a lot of fun
flexibility and that you can run your
function in your ideal environment
so up into this point I pretty much
talked exclusively about consumption
functions these are functions that run
in the service plan you only pay for
what you use we only allocate resources
for you on-demand but that's only one of
the many different flavors that your
functions can run in you can run your
Asha functions in what's called an app
service plan this is like the website
plan inside of Azure and this plan
allows you to reserve and have reserve
capacity for your functions so instead
of saying hey spin these up on the man
you could say hey I want twenty
instances that are my instances that I
can manage how I want choose different
hardware configurations maybe even have
websites or other processes running on
top of it you can still deploy your
functions to run there you can run in
your own dedicated isolated environments
connected to things like V nets you can
run on premises with Azure stack there's
also an on-premises which is called as
your functions runtime which is similar
to the runtime I just had in Visual
Studio which doesn't require the full
Azure stack and finally you can run your
Azure functions on IOT devices so that
same function that I just wrote at the
beginning if I wanted to when I've done
demos like this before if I had a
Raspberry Pi sitting next to me like a
really simple IOT device I could deploy
and have that function run on that IOT
device as well connected or disconnected
so you can have kind of take advantage
of this programming model but then host
it in the environment that best fits you
ok so we've got about 20 minutes left
we'll probably maybe even finished a
little bit early in case there's
questions and this is the last session
so the last thing I want to talk about
is how you can orchestrate processes
with functions you saw at the beginning
during that doorbell example how I used
as your logic apps to kind of create
that process to process the video but
there's actually another way that you
can process your your functions and
orchestrate data and the other way that
I want to spend the rest of the time
talking about is a newer piece of Azure
functions which is again very unique to
Azure inside of service is called Azure
durable functions I have screenshots of
durable functions up here on the right
or your left I'm sorry on the left
as your directions are hard durable
functions you'll see here I have one
example here in JavaScript and one
example here in c-sharp and what I've
actually done here is I'm able to
describe orchestrating and calling
different functions and activities but
I'm describing that all through code so
to kind of help illustrate why this
might be needed for one if I'm running
in a microservices environment which
serverless is a natural fit and some of
these like single function single piece
of functionality type mentality that
microservices bring it's very often that
to do something I'm gonna need to call
multiple of these things so durable
functions in logic apps are a great way
to call multiple but the other thing to
be aware of is for server lists and the
server list plan a single function can
only run for a maximum of 10 minutes
which means if you have a piece of data
or some processing that needs to occur
that may be running much longer than 10
minutes that becomes very difficult to
manage and you have to end up splitting
up the task and without something like
durable functions or logic gaps you end
up having to create queues and do
everything yourself here with durable
functions and with logic apps you can
actually run things that last for a very
long time and we will manage the
orchestration and state for you so that
these can run indefinitely so let's talk
about as your durable functions it's an
extension that you can pull into your
app there's a bunch of documentation on
this I'd encourage you to look at look
at that documentation as well because
I'm not gonna be able to do it justice
here in the last 15 minutes it enables
you to run these long-running and
stateful serverless orchestrations you
can write these in c-sharp or in
JavaScript right now this slide isn't
fully up to date I guess JavaScript just
got announced last month this will
manage the state the checkpoints the
queuing all for you it's built on top of
some open source technology called the
durable task framework which is just an
open source framework to enable you to
durably execute things so it's very nice
to be able to manage things so a few
patterns that it solves for just to give
you another flavor it's kind of like
function chaining I have function one I
want to call function to them function
three function 4
without durable I would end up having to
do something like this where I would
drop a message into a queue this one
would have to pick it up from a queue
and so forth that gets really
challenging to manage and to monitor and
to version with durable functions I can
just write c-sharp code to say call
function 1 then function to them
function 3 another popular one this is
what I'm going to show a demo in just a
second of is doing some like distributed
fan-out fanon or MapReduce type of
patterns where maybe you get a bunch of
data and you want to process it across a
number of parallel executions and you
can describe this all again in code a
synchronous response is where you want
to return back a status endpoint and be
able to a pole until the long-running
work is complete maybe you have some
work that might take 5 minutes to
execute and you don't want to have to
keep an HTTP request open for five
minutes
durable will provide out-of-the-box
patterns for you to say hey return back
an immediate response and then do the
work in the background and let them
check to find out when the work is done
super super useful pattern monitoring
saying things like hey go watch this
value for the next hour or the next day
and tell me if something changes human
interaction one of the cool demos and
samples we have with durable functions
is doing like a text validation pattern
where you send somebody a code and you
wait for them to put that code into like
a website or to text that code to a
number it might take them three days
before they finally read that text
message and send back the text but you
could wait that long for that
interaction and tie all that together
obviously if it's like a authentication
thing you don't want to wait that long
but I'm just saying they can run for a
very long time and again this is exactly
something dropped that scared me this is
an example of that first pattern
function chaining but in c-sharp I just
say hey call function 1 then call
function to call function 3 I'm even
passing in inputs so I can pull data and
push data between and then all of the
rest gets managed for me let's show it
an example really quick before I do this
piece I'll do this piece a little bit
out of order so I want to show you this
in action so I have an example very
quickly we
I have a website let me show you the
website first this is a website that's
powered by service technology it's
beautiful it was written by one of the
azure cloud advocates it's a simple
store I could come in here and add some
items go ahead and check out but the
nice thing about this function is that
whenever somebody Plato this is an email
not not my credit card when any whenever
anybody comes in here and places in
order let me make sure I put in the
right test credit card number it's
actually right here when I push pay it's
calling an azure function behind the
scenes and processing this all server
lessly
so that the order process piece doesn't
actually take any compute out of my
website now this is using cosmos DB
behind the scenes to store all of these
orders and what I want to be able to do
is generate a report so I want to go and
say hey look at my database and give me
the last seven days of orders and for
each of those orders there could have
been 1,000 orders or 10,000 orders I
want you to go and get the current
status of that order like hey is the
payment been processed has it been
shipped has it been delivered what's the
status of that order and then returned
to me a report now if I was trying to do
this without durable this would be
really difficult cuz this middle step
here could take a really long time if I
had a thousand orders that had been
placed and I have to do a lookup of a
database for each of those thousand
orders that could take an hour I don't
know it depends on how slow my databases
there's no way I could execute that all
in a single function but with durable
functions I'm able to chain this
together in code I'll show you briefly
what this looks like and then show you
what it looks like actually I'll show
you the demo first let me open it up
right here and while I wait for this to
open let's go ahead and call that report
so I have here a URL not this URL
you can see a test of this I'm gonna go
ahead and kick off this process to
generate a report so I just put in the
URL to that report up here and what it's
immediately returned to me back is some
data it said hey I've gone ahead and
kicked off this process this is the URL
you can follow to get the status if you
want to add some data you can post some
data here or if you want to terminate
this I can terminate here let's just go
ahead and click the status endpoint and
hopefully I didn't talk too long and
this will still be running it already
completed so let's do it again
it ran too fast let's run another one
and I'm going to click that status
endpoint cuz I want to show you it does
so you can see right here it's still
running right it's still right now it's
looking at cosmos it's spun up a bunch
of parallel functions to go look up the
status of the database and it's telling
me that it's running right now and if I
go ahead and refresh this depending on
how much data I had it could have still
said running but in this case it's
completed announcer deported data which
said hey you have four that are
preparing for shipment one that shipped
four that are delivered and two that are
being processed so I was able to build
this pattern but have it all running as
functions and the code here just to give
you another sense of what a durable
function looks like this is the
orchestration all in c-sharp so the
first thing that I do is I say hey go
get all of the transactions from cosmos
DB so that's going to call a function
that gets all my transactions from
cosmos I'm gonna do a for each loop to
create a bunch of parallel tasks so for
every single transaction I've had I'm
gonna go and call the git process
function and here I can just say wait
for all of these to be done and again
this when all could take an hour it
could take two hours what's really cool
here with durable function that's hard
to wrap your mind around is that this
function isn't actually going to be
running the entire time whenever there's
this awake keyword it's actually going
to go to sleep and wait for them to all
complete and that will trigger it to
wake up and continue and then it will
return all the details so a lot of tech
here it's pretty advanced in a little
bit complex but it's worth knowing it
maybe to help visualize that the last
thing I'll show you is is how this
durable function is running behind the
scenes what's actually happening here
how are we able to run these
long-running processes
still have it be service not having to
pay a bunch of money so here I have a
very simple orchestration this is in
c-sharp all I'm saying is create a new
list call this function called say hello
it says Amsterdam I should have updated
my slides I'm sorry I've been doing too
much traveling this week and then add
that to a list okay
but hello anyone who's watching this
stream from Amsterdam once it's
published and that's it so what actually
happens is my orchestration is gonna
start it's gonna run this first line of
code and so it creates a new list and
it's going to see this await word and
when it sees this await word there's
this thing called the execution history
and the first thing it's going to do is
it's going to look at the execution
history and it's going to say hey have
already done this action have already
had this function have it say hello to
Amsterdam and in this case I haven't so
it's gonna say nope you haven't done
this before
the orchestrator is like okay cool I'm
gonna do this then so it's gonna call
that function it's gonna say hey
function you have some work to do that
activity functions and then sorry it's
gonna call that function and then you're
gonna notice that Orchestrator is gonna
go to sleep it's gonna scale the zero
it's gonna disappear it's done for now
the activity function gets triggered
it's been told that has some work to do
it executes the work and in this case
the response is hello Amsterdam should
say hello Norway I'm sorry that
functions done that function goes to
sleep and you'll notice all of this has
been stored in the execution history now
once that activity function is done it
wakes up the orchestrator so now my
Orchestrator wakes back up but here's
the part that's important to understand
when that Orchestrator wakes back up
it doesn't start from this line right
here it starts from the very beginning
again because there's no way to just
like resume a program from the very
middle after you've scaled to zero so
the first thing it's gonna do is it's
going to create a new list now it's
going to see this awake keyword and it's
going to look at the execution history
it's gonna say hey have we already
called Amsterdam or say hello Amsterdam
in this case it has like it's already
done that action so my history is like
yep you've already done this thing
Marcus Tudor says great I'm gonna move
on and do my next step
and then it's going to continue to do
its next step and then return back the
responses so every time one of these
functions is completed my orchestration
is going to replay now that's extremely
important to know because this impacts
what your Orchestrator can do it is very
important to know that your Orchestrator
code must be deterministic you cannot
have values in your orchestration that
will be different every time it runs so
for example maybe I have an if condition
I don't want to say if date/time dot now
equal equals something right because
every time that code gets replayed the
date time is going to be different or if
I generate a grid that grid is going to
be generated different on every single
replay and it can corrupt my state so
never write logic that depends on random
numbers date time or grids okay don't do
i/o inside of an Orchestrator function
do your i/o inside of your activities
don't write infinite loops that's just a
good rule in general I figured we should
throw it in every tech don't write
infinite loops make sure that these
things terminate there are patterns
though for all of these so if you have
something that is running infinitely
there is a safe way to do this endurable
that doesn't result in you having
infinite replays there are ways to do
i/o inside of your activities and there
are ways to do like get a current date
time or generate a grid or generate a
random number but you need to make sure
you're leveraging the built-in pieces of
functionality we have in the
orchestrator that enable us to do this
in a deterministic way okay so again a
lot of kind of advanced concepts here
with durable functions but they're
extremely powerful for you
the last thing I'll finish with is we've
shown two ways to orchestrate data now
we've shown just recently durable
functions which they should do it in
code at the beginning we showed you
logic apps which lets you do it in that
kind of visual designer that I showed
you so which one should you use durable
functions is a stateful process
Orchestrator not necessarily an
integration service so logic apps has a
bunch of out-of-the-box connectors it
has things like Edda fact and x12 and
the types of things you would expect
from
servus almost like BizTalk server
durable is not that rich in those types
of features so if you're looking at
something that's doing integration at
that level logic apps may be the better
fit however there is a lot of healthy
overlap between the two so a lot of it
comes down to personal preference in
fact a lot of times I'll talk with
developers and they're like you know
what I really like how fast I can build
things and chain them together and
visualize them inside of logic apps so
I'm gonna use this declarative workflow
in other people who are like hey I'm
writing code all day I think in code I'd
rather be writing this inside of code in
kind of an imperative fashion that's
totally cool that's fine I do whatever
one makes you happy
understanding some of the differences in
how they execute for example logic apps
doesn't do that replay between every
execution it will just do action than
action than action than action durable
has that replayability these to mix and
match together very well and if you're
interested there's even another duck
there but just use whatever makes you
happy that's just a general good rule
for all technology okay so that's it for
the content I wanted to share with you
again thank you so much for coming I'll
hang around here for a few minutes
afterwards and answer any questions if
you're interested in learning more
getting started I'd encourage you to
look at our documentation especially
durable functions there's like ten
pieces of Docs and a bunch of samples to
get you started if you're interested in
trying it out it's extremely powerful
because you can get these long-running
processes with the benefits of server
lists we also have a number of
QuickStart so if you haven't ever built
a function before we have one where you
can do it all within the portal we have
some for visual studio we have some for
visual studio code whatever editor makes
you happy even some that just use the
command line we've got a bunch of
samples and then some of the advance
patterns I've talked about like instance
management concurrency control in order
messaging error handling I've written a
few of these in my own personal blog if
you're interested which is at medium.com
slash at jeff hall and it's also my
twitter handle i'm more than happy to
answer any questions you may have there
so with that that's it so thank you all
very much for coming I'll go ahead and
answer any questions there's not a bunch
of people in the room so if you have any
questions go
head and then please just as you leave
you get the little feedback slips this
is my first time coming to NDC I'm
learning exactly how best to do this
they stuck me at the very end of the
last day because I was a late entry but
even just those feedback slips will help
me know how to improve and hopefully get
me invited back as well so thank you all
very much
any questions I can answer while we're
here are we all good oh yes one right
here good question so the question for
those who didn't hear is do the new
dotnet core questions get around
assembly redirect stuff so this is a
good questions a very common one the the
challenge that we had with the version
one of Asher functions was that for
dotnet function specifically the desire
was to let you have access to very rich
data types in fact if you look at this
example that I had at the beginning
where I was pulling in data from cosmos
DB I could as I mentioned like I could
say hey I want to push a string to
cosmos DB but I could also say I want to
pass in a cosmos DB document like this
is a very rich data type that comes
directly from the cosmos DB SDK and the
way that this is possible is we wanted
you to be able to pass rich data types
between your function and the host
process and there's a really good idea
at the time and that's how it was built
but the challenge with that is that it
means that now your function has some
dependencies on the assemblies that the
host is using that host process so if
you want to do something like use a
newer version of cosmos DB then what the
host is using if you try to do that
you're going to get Assembly resolution
errors when you try to run it especially
when you try to pass data in between
because it's like hey this is document
version 2 and I use document version 1
so there's a lot of consternation there
so one of the big things we've been
doing with version 2 is helping improve
that the short answer is just now the
release that just completed improved a
bunch of scenarios in fact 95% of the
scenarios we were tracking are now much
more possible today but we're not done
yet
the next piece we want to do which
should be available in preview by the
end of the year would allow you to run
your
c-sharp functions completely in a
separate process doing whatever you want
on those it does make it so that things
like rich data type transfer would work
differently because we're gonna have to
like serialize and pass the data but the
long story or I guess the short story is
give it a shot in the B to one there's
like you know a bunch of things that
weren't possible that now we've we've
worked very closely with the dotnet core
team to have specific assembly load
context for your function so that you
can pull in whatever extensions you want
and run them independently but we're
gonna continue to work on this through
the end a year so that we never have
anybody who SSS is that so good question
though
definitely very high priority any other
questions yep yeah good question so the
question was again for those who didn't
hear Python support so we actually have
Python running right now in private
preview which is funny to say I and we
can give invitations to really anybody
who's interested just just sent me a
note on Twitter
so yes it is coming it's it's available
right now we have Python workers I built
a few of these myself it's not yet in
public preview yet it should be in the
coming weeks but if you're interested in
giving it a shot I'd encourage you to
get onboard the private preview now and
then keep an eye out in the next few
weeks and hopefully you'll see an
announcement where you can use it
publicly and then as the version 2
becomes generally available it would
come available after that as well
ok any other ones yep go ahead functions
with exceptions you said what happens to
it yep
so when your function has an exception
is that like if you threw an exception
in here oh and no reference in sight
yeah so just like any except like if I
wrote code here and I tried to like
Poland request body and request body was
no like what would happen yeah so Jen
when exceptions get thrown your code
just finishes and could go away and
that's another really important thing to
note is the trigger that you're using so
for an HTTP trigger for example if I
have an exception that I don't catch and
handle in my code it's very possible
that that request just vanished into
in air and I would have lost that data
okay so one thing is that you can like
catch exceptions in your code directly
some of our triggers though do have
automatic retries so if this was coming
from a cue instead of a HTTP trigger if
you had something like a no ref
exception we would actually
automatically go and retry that a number
of times and if all of them result in
exceptions and we retry five times we'll
actually go ahead and stick that in a
poison cue or a dead letter Q so that
you can see hey you know this message
had an error and and it ended up being a
poison Q so monitoring helps with that
the trigger type is the biggest one on
this one now if you have data that you
want to make sure you don't lose make
sure you use a trigger that can keep
some state around like a Q does that
help was that the question okay cool
all right we'll go with one more go
ahead mmm great question so I mentioned
how these connection strings are
environment variables in the cloud you
would put this type of a connection
string in an app setting which is
encrypted but a lot of people want to
keep these in key vault so by the end of
this summer we plan to have a feature
where instead of me having to put my
connection string directly in an app
setting I would actually be able to do
something like key vault something
something something and have an address
to where that secret lives inside of my
Azure key vault and we would fetch it
out of key vault for you using the
managed service identity so it's being
worked on right now targeted to around
the end of the summer where you could
reference secrets coming from key vault
instead of having to put them directly
in your environment variables okay all
right I think that's everyone then
thanks again so much enjoy your weekend
five twenty on the dot
appreciate you all staying honestly I
can't remember the last time I went to
the last session of a conference so I
appreciate you all being here if I had
swag I would give it to you so thanks
again so much